joe jonas and sophie turner are
officially a family of four after
welcoming baby number two i'm so excited
about it and so are we sophie's rep
confirmed the happy news to et
announcing joe and sophie are now proud
parents of a second little girl their
first daughter willa will celebrate her
second birthday later this month it's
gonna be a party now as a party of four
we can only imagine joe and sophie are
soaking up every second with their
newest bundle of joy back in march a
source told e.t they were overjoyed
about having a second kiddo noting they
both have siblings and didn't want their
little girl to be an only child
they have always talked about having a
bigger family
it's
amazing also amazing how sophie and joe
have kept things so private when it
comes to their fam
it wasn't until the actress was well
into her second pregnancy that she
revealed the exciting news by showing
off her baby bump for elle's uk june
issue that's where sophie gushed about
motherhood telling the mad quote it's
what life is about for me raising the
next generation the greatest thing in
life is seeing my daughter go from
strength to strength we're so excited to
be expanding the family it's the best
blessing ever as for jokes since
becoming a dad he's learned to balance
work and personal life last year he
opened up to cbs mornings about home
life with sophie and their daughter amid
the pandemic it's been amazing um this
it's been force time at home you know i
think i'm always on the go i'm always
moving and traveling and touring
and to be in one place for a solid
amount of time and just have my feet on
the ground and be with my family my
immediate family
is time i i don't think i'll i'll get
back and so i i'm so thankful and
grateful of course joe's got his
brothers to bond with over all things
dad life older bro kevin is dad to two
girls too while little bro nick just
welcomed his first daughter malty
earlier this year you posted a beautiful
picture of you and malty um what how's
fatherhood been for you because
everybody says it's life-changing to you
it is certainly life-changing she's uh
she's amazing um brings me a lot of joy
she's actually here not here right now
but she's in tahoe and all is good
[Music]